[Music]
we also in the age of people charged
with sexual misconduct yeah this is
everywhere how do you react to that
especially you as the father of four
girls I think it's wonderful that women
who are feeling empowered to tell their
stories and and it's totally necessary
Matt Damon sharing his thoughts on
sexual misconduct allegations in a new
interview with ABC News is popcorn with
Peter Travers but the actor is under
fire for making this comment I do
believe that that there's a spectrum of
behavior right and and we're gonna have
to figure out like what you know there's
a there's a difference between you know
patting someone on the butt and rape or
child molestation right both of those
behaviors need to be confronted and
eradicated without question but they
shouldn't be conflated the interview got
his name trending on Twitter and Matt's
Good Will Hunting co-star Minnie Driver
is one of many upset by his comments she
responded with God God seriously Minnie
and Matt worked with accused Hollywood
producer Harvey Weinstein on the movie
the actor also made this comparison when
you see Al Franken taking a picture
where he's putting his hands on the venn
woman's black jacket and and mugging for
the camera going like that you know that
is like a just a terrible joke and it's
not funny and it's wrong he should have
done that and I mean Gail Collins said
in the New York time the caption of that
picture should have just read I'm a
comedian who's never gonna run for say
yeah but but when you talk about Harvey
and what what what is he's accused of
there are no pictures of that right he
knew he was up to no good
that stuff happened secretly because it
was criminal and he knew it right and so
there there is they don't belong in the
same category Weinstein has denied any
allegations of non-consensual sex